un tensioactifs du carbonate de sodium
du citrate de sodium et des huiles
essentielles quatre ingrédients pour
fabriquer un produit ménager dégraissant
merlin le prête à frotter écologique a
été créé par un versailles et il se
présente sous forme de sachets contenant
des principes actifs en poudre à diluer
chez soi
il suffit de deux cuillères à café de
ces principes actifs
mélanger à 500000 du taux et de ce cui
merlin c'est l'idée de changer un peu la
donne sur les produits d'entretien
aujourd'hui un produit d'entretien
classique c'est beaucoup d'eau et puis
avec des substances qui sont parfois
dangereuses nos pièces de changer la
donne désir allons à l'essentiel ne
vendons que les actifs sous la forme
d'une poudre le format le plus pur
possible que l'on dit lui à la maison
ajoutez à cela les principes actifs sont
vendus dans un mini sachet en vrac
recyclables et 80 % des ingrédients sont
issus de la valorisation des biodéchets
cet ancien salarié remarketing à une
prise de conscience lors d'une
expérience de volontariat haïti là bas
il fallait gérer nous mêmes nos déchets
donc forcément quand on gère somme ces
déchets on se pose toujours la question
j'achète ce produit là que ce que je
vais en faire une fois que cela sera
terminé de ça forcément quand on a on
est rentré j'ai eu envie d'agir de
contribuer par parce que je faisais
d'abord par en changeant la consommation
réduire l'impact écologique en achetant
français et en utilisant des matières
renouvelables
voilà l'idée du produit la marque merlin
n'est pas encore commercialisé mais
maxime giroux a créé une campagne de
financement participatif sur une bulle
et après la campagne sera disponible en
e-commerce et j'espère très vite dans
les boutiques bio
le fondateur de marlène participants
parallèle au concours de la fabrique
aviva dont il a passé la première phase
la deuxième se tiendra le 23 mars
prochain
objectif récolter 60 mille euros